[Musique]
car j'adore les plus grandes sélections
du monde se termine aujourd'hui en inde
depuis des semaines ya près de 900
millions d'électeurs qui ont été appelés
à voter pour le prochain gouvernement
on en parle tout de suite avec sébastien
farsi correspondant de radio france
internationale et de radio canada à
delhi bonjour sébastien jours alors
vraiment ce sont des chiffres
astronomiques quand on regarde ça des
centaines de millions de personnes
appelées aux urnes
quel bilan dresses quant au déroulement
des élections
le déroulement et a été assez pacifique
c'est une énorme campagne bien sûr
amener sur six semaines sept jours de
vote différents qu'il faut organiser
dans des régions très différentes depuis
les montagnes de l'himalaya 4500 mètres
jusqu'au désert du rajasthan et à chaque
fois transporté les urnes pouvoir
organiser ces élections qui fonctionne
par machine électronique à voter au
compte un million de bureaux de vote et
10 millions de fonctionnaires pour
organiser ces élections donc c'est
vraiment massif est la raison pour
laquelle s'est étendue sur une telle
durée c'est que il y avait il ya aussi
des zones qui sont très perturbés hélas
le cachemire les des zones contrôlées
par les maoïstes et à chaque fois des
déploiements de militaires sont
nécessaires
donc c'est dans l'ensemble pacifique
bien le combler on s'attend au résultat
en fait dès le jeudi prochain le dernier
jour de vote et est aujourd'hui est-ce
qu'on a une idée du taux de
participation à ces élections
oui c'est assez élevé on les différentes
faces enfin assez élevé environ les deux
tiers des des électeurs se sont se sont
déplacés ce qui est dans la moyenne en
général des dernières législatives
c'est bon quand même quels sont les
enjeux
actuellement les enjeux sont vraiment
très binaire d'un côté on a un parti
nationaliste hindou le bjp menée par le
premier ministre au pouvoir qui a en
fait changé énormément le
la politique indienne la manière de
faire la politique ainsi que la place de
la religion replace l hindouisme au
centre de la politique ce qui n'était
pas arrivé depuis 70 ans depuis que
l'inde existe en affirmant que
l'hindouisme devenait de devait devenir
la religion quasiment officiel de l'inde
alors que nous sommes dans une
république laïque aujourd'hui favoriser
tout l'introduction de l'hindouisme dans
la société réprimer énormément les
musulmans qui composent 13% de la
population et donc une politique très
agressive qui a vraiment mener le bjp a
favorisé des candidats très radicaux
dans cette campagne et face à et face au
bjp le congrès un parti laïc un parti
qui a dominé la politique indienne
depuis soixante dix ans mais qui ont
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition et qui a
du mal à se faire entendre mais qui
voilà qui met en avant plutôt d'une
politique sociale en faveur des pauvres
et une politique laïque surtout donc on
a vraiment affaire à deux deux parties
très différents d'un côté un parti très
religieux les musulmans très effrayée
par une possible reconduite de ce parti
et puis de l'autre côté le congrès qui
lui essaye de revenir à quelque chose de
plus laïque et et en faveur des pauvres
voilà sébastien je lisais à des
observateurs qui affirmait que c'était
la démocratie indienne qui était en jeu
avec le scrutin actuel surtout si le
premier ministre sortant a annoncé est
reconduit oui tout à fait la reine
rameau dit mais c'est plus que d'abord
il ya bien sûr la place de la religion
le fait que nous parlons vraiment d'un
suprématisme hindous donc d'une
domination une répression une
ostracisation des musulmans donc qui est
bien sûr condamné par beaucoup
d'organisations des droits de l'homme
les musulmans sont tabassés assassiné et
les ministres du bjp souvent les
félicite ces criminels donc on a
vraiment affaire à une question de
droits de l'homme et puis plus large
plus largement le premier ministre un
drame audi est devenu une sorte de
deux figures au dessus de la politique
qui se présente comme le gardien le seul
maître de la nation et il a tendance à
devenir une sorte de dictateur en tout
cas de leader très autoritaire qui
n'autorise pas les opposants à
s'exprimer ou qui les dévalorise les
appelle les ennemis de la nation donc
une vraie offensive autoritaire et c'est
là où on peut parler en effet de la
démocratie indienne en danger est ce que
s'il n'a rien drame audi revient au
pouvoir il va respecter l'opposition
respecter la cour suprême l'a
l'indépendance de la justice c'est bien
sûr toutes les valeurs démocratiques qui
sont en jeu aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il a
des chances réelles d'autres arrêts
lunaire un drame audi
le bjp a en effet deschamps si c'est
très difficile de prévoir bien sûr le
vote de tapei aussi large très diverse
300 millions de personnes qui sont sur
le niveau de pauvreté qui qui vote et
qui décident à la dernière minute donc
encore très difficile de faire quelques
pronostics que ce soit mais en effet
narendra modi son parti semble favori en
tout cas pour obtenir une majorité
relative donc pouvoir former un
gouvernement mais avec quelle coalition
c'est la la la la question à partir du
23 mai à partir de jeudi prochain on
aura vraiment les résultats et on pourra
dire est ce que si le bjp doit former
une coalition avec d'autres partis
régionaux est-ce que sa politique devra
changer ce qui devrait atténuer sa
politique hindouiste respecter plus
l'opposition c'est justement ce
qu'espère tout le monde pour pouvoir
atténuer cette politique suprémacistes
aujourd'hui le bjp a une majorité
absolue à la chambre tous les pouvoirs
donc c'est aujourd'hui on s'attend quand
même à ce que le bjp réduise sa prise
son contrôle sur la chambre donc ce qui
pourrait en quelque sorte servir d'
équilibre démocratique à son pouvant pas
mais on s'attend en effet à ce qu'ils
soient reconduits narendra modi lui sera
choisie par la marque la majorité de la
chambre
on sait pas si ce sera lui ou un autre
leader du bjp mais il est tellement
essentiel au bjp qu' il est forte à
penser qu'il sera plébiscité par son
parti encore une fois très bien alors
derniers jours de vote aujourd'hui en
souhaitant aux dépôts et tout ça les
résultats à partir de
23 mai merci beaucoup sébastien faire
c'est d'être avec nous ce matin en
direct de new delhi
merci à vous